i don't really know what we're going to
do if this drought condition continues
ronald longley is like many of us
worried about our water future but he's
doing what he can to conserve it's very
concerning we're following the
guidelines you don't water on sundays
and only so many days a week and during
certain hours and you try to be
responsible about it and bronson mack
with the las vegas valley water district
says the likelihood of the water levels
declining even more so next year are
real we do expect that water levels in
lake mead are going to continue to
decline there is a very high probability
that we could move to the next level of
shortage next year nevada is currently
at the first tier of the three-tier
level system and the bureau of
reclamation projects that it will be at
tier 2a by next january so what does
that mean for valley residents moving
forward expect smaller pools in the
future and tighter water budgets for
golf courses the future is in our hands
and it's all about saving water and
especially outdoors mac recommends
sticking to the watering schedule and
never watering on sundays
and as for understanding the tier levels
again we are now in tier one with the
likelihood of phasing into tier two a by
next year but that projection will
officially be made in august denise